we're learning that one of the navy's
nuclear-powered submarines hit an
underwater object in the south china sea
last saturday eleven sailors on board
were injured and the navy says the sub
is fully operational raymie nolcenzio is
with us in hong kong raymie good morning
nate good morning that's right u.s
military officials are saying that they
waited five days before going public
with this news in order to maintain
operational security now the sub in
question is the uss connecticut it's
classified as a seawolf class fast
attack submarine and in a statement the
u.s pacific fleet says it's in safe and
stable condition that its nuclear
propulsion plan was not impacted and no
one sustained life-threatening injuries
now this incident though of course is
happening at a time of high tensions
between beijing and washington just
weeks after the u.s and the uk signed a
deal to supply nuclear-powered subs to
australia and really just days after
china sent a record number of military
aircraft near taiwan
china today expressed grave concerns
urging the u.s to give details about the
sub's mission and questioning whether it
may have caused a nuclear leak under the
sea as for the uss connecticut it was
last reported to be making its way to
the u.s territory of guam u.s military
officials say that it did not hit
another submarine but it might have hit
some kind of container or some kind of
submerged vessel the u.s of course says
it will con continue to investigate
raymie in hosencio for us in hong kong
raymie thank you very much